you know Tom I'm really ready to shoot
something is there a chance is there any
way in this reality that I can shoot
stuff yeah yeah we we can have you
trained to be a space pirate space
pirate yeah okay
you ready for that I will there be any
sex in this at all this looks like Los
Angeles the porn capital of the world
see your engineers are already starting
to move in the right direction okay take
a look at your hands yes I have guns
okay you can also have a shield if you
reach into your backpack yeah with your
right hand there okay okay that's looks
like a birth control device okay so turn
that's not a shield what is that oh yes
a sex toy look at it you guys are
finally starting to get it oh yeah I
could have fun with this
yes
they get killed this so beats mundane
office work that's really fun
you